[Music]
school romance stories are appealing
because of their relatable nature they
usually have a great mix of
heart-wrenching hilarious and cute
moments welcome to Vinnie tube and today
we're going through ten of the best
school romance anime that you need to
watch keep in mind the anime that were
in the top 10 anime that will make you
cry have been excluded from this list as
that video was made recently if you
haven't seen that video do make sure you
check it out though number 10 we have
Kim Anita Doki this is the story of
Sawako an unassuming honest high school
girl in search of friendship but her
resemblance to the horror film character
Sadako makes this difficult being an
outcast from a young age has made her
socially awkward and stigmatized when
her idol the popular boy car hire begins
talking to her everything changes she
finds herself in a new world making new
friends and talking to different people
now being able to express her feelings
to her friends
Tomiko realizes she has special feelings
for cars I hire a sweet love blossoms
between the two as they overcome
circumstances and obstacles that stand
in their way it's a really great feel
good anime that will never fail to tug
at your heartstrings
[Music]
she looks animal hug Iverson's I see
Geordi with no Katya how they are gonna
be best or
moving on to number nine its sukiyaki
Rae this romantic journey introduces us
to Akane Mizuno and Kotaro
Izumi - third year middle school
students who become classmates for the
first time
Akane is a member of the school track
team and Kotaro is the literary club
president who loves books and wants to
become a writer the two are put in
charge of the equipment for the Sports
Festival and slowly grow closer over
time as much as the two seem an unlikely
romantic pair their experiences in
school along with the other students
makes them mature and aware of personal
changes the series delivers an exciting
heartwarming story that connected
reality this might be a slow burner for
some folks but it's definitely one of
the most relatable and realistic romance
anime you'll ever watch
[Music]
on to number eight is the pet girl of
Sakura Seoul the main protagonist of
this series is Candice errata a student
of Sakura dormitory after getting kicked
out of the main dorms for bringing in a
stray cat serrata is forced to live in
the small sakura halls where problem
students are sent although he doesn't
mind his roommates sirata can't wait to
move out but when sheena Mashiro moves
into the dorm everything changes as time
goes by we see sera to develop emotional
feelings towards mashiro the story is
about their daily lives as well as
mental and emotional growth it has a
really good mixture of funny sad and
heartwarming moments
[Music]
next on the list at number seven it's
Dora Dora this series centers on busy
body high school student Ryoji who
people avoid because he's inherited the
evil looking eyes and facial structure
of his Yakuza father he meets his
self-centered and tiny neighbor or
should I say a lowly Sondre tiger aisaka
and over the course of the anime Ryu G
and Tiger sets up romantic situations to
help each other get to know their
friends but many of them backfire the
series follows the lives of these
friends and how love blossoms among them
I could see people putting this series
higher in their lists but personally I
found Tiger annoying a lot of the times
even the real G is a likeable character
Jimmy Aceveda canola yard continued
chuckles get a hug here
[Music]
and number six
it's the anthem of the heart this story
revolves around Jun Naru say a young
girl known for being such a chatterbox
that she inadvertently caused her
parents divorce as a child a fairy egg
cursed her so that she would never hurt
anyone else the story then skips forward
a few years where she meets poor
high-school student Takumi sakagami as
the two spent time together preparing
for the musical Jun starts to develop
feelings for Takumi the film beautifully
conveys its themes with good music and
voice acting performances along with
great animation from a-1 pictures
overall this romantic musical is
brilliantly written and delivers on all
fronts so low-key as a circus act
so
koko kara has McDonagh book touching on
1 over Korea moving one to number 5 we
have a series which aired recently it's
Roscoe does not dream of bunny girl
senpai high school students circle does
life takes a twist when he sees a bunny
girl known as my Sakurajima appear
before him she circled his upper
classmen and a famous actress on hiatus
from the entertainment industry mais
intrigue the suckled is the only one who
can see her the rumor about the
mysterious phenomenon called puberty
syndrome has impose 'old so sir cooter
unfolds the meaning behind his bizarre
encounters on women with this syndrome
what makes this anime so good is the
interaction and the chemistry between
the two main characters this was
definitely one of the best non-sequel
anime of 2018
[Music]
next on the list at number four we have
kids on the slope this anime series
centers on male protagonists Karuna she
me who's a first-year high school
student due to his father's work he
moves out to Sasebo Nagasaki prefecture
Japan to live with relatives until then
carol was an honor roll student who kept
to himself
but meeting the notorious bad-boy
Sentaro changed him through his
devil-may-care classmate cao lu learns
how much fun it is to play jazz and
finds the first person he can call a
real friend he also meets the beautiful
rich Zuko who he ends up falling in love
with the series is directed by Shinichi
drew watanabe known for cowboy bebop and
samurai Champloo with a smooth blend of
music and drama this anime series proved
to be an entertaining romantic
rollercoaster at number three it's my
teen romantic comedy snafu this anime is
about an anti-social and cynical high
school student named Ho Chi Minh who has
a distorted view on life his life
changes when he's forced to enter the
volunteer service club by his teacher
and this is where he meets an equally
problematic student Yukino they provide
help for any troubled schoolmate who
requests there soon they meet the
cheerful ue and together they form a
trio in this romantic comedy
what makes this anime stand out is the
amazing MC in his quotes about society
it has some great dialogue that blends
in with wit and sarcasm it largely
depicts various social situations faced
by teens in a high school setting and
the psychology driving their
interactions Horan was his ghost corner
took the little combo how do you mean
mr. Chi is a Kiara Tessa
at number 2 we have real-life the story
revolves around 27 year old erotica Zaki
he's been unemployed for years after
quitting a job just after three months
claiming that it didn't fulfill his
highest potential as a result he finds
it difficult to gain a job at another
company and his life changes when he
meets a man who
for him a drug that can change his
appearance to that of a 17 year old
after taking the drug he becomes the
subject in a year-long experiment in
which he begins his life as a high
school student again there he meets
Chizu Roja Shiro smart but socially
awkward his Shiro is ignorant to any non
school matters particularly social and
emotional ones through connecting with
her friends and other classmates errata
must find what she lacks to live a happy
life in the real world within a one-year
time limit the romance is cute but
nothing extraordinary
what makes this series interesting is
the plot and our artists struggle to
adjust to his new lifestyle and avoid
repeating his past mistakes and finally
at number one we have I want to eat your
pancreas I got dozens of comments on my
top 10 anime that will make you cry
video asking why I didn't include this
now that's because I haven't seen it for
some reason this anime has been under
the radar but after watching it I
definitely say it's one of the best
anime movies I've seen in recent times
definitely it should be on everyone's
watchlist
now despite its creepy name I can assure
you there's no cannibalism involved in
this anime I want to eat your pancreas
is a sad story between two high school
students the male lead finds a book
titled living with dying which belongs
to Sakura
now Sakura is diagnosed with pancreatic
cancer and doesn't have much time left
to live after that meeting the pair
begin to spend the girls remaining time
together the protagonist of this series
is antisocial and doesn't have any
friends which is the opposite of Sakura
who's popular and cheerful we see the
protagonists growth and how Sakura helps
him become a better person throughout
the story this is more of a drama than a
romance like a silent voice but it's
definitely an anime everyone should
check out because of its beautiful
portrayal of a unique and special
relationship between 2p
[Music]
so what do you think of this list and
what's your favorite school romance
anime comment below and let us know
don't forget to hit that like button if
you enjoyed the video and subscribe to
the channel if you haven't done so
already you won't regret it I'll see you
next time on Vinnie Chu
no silly bear my gosh you like that
[Music]
or not you may want me down